let's try
instead
zach from st louis i feel like it's been
a while since we've heard from anybody
from uh from st louis
zach from st louis you're on what's
going on today
hey david thanks for uh picking on me um
appreciate everything you do by the way
thank you
uh in regards to covid this is a
conversation i've been having frequently
with uh family and friends um you know
taking it back home from afghanistan for
a minute is how do we come back from
this edge we're on you know there's a
there's a set of people who
and i've just i've kind of looked at the
anti-mask anti-vaccine people as two
camps okay um the people who are going
out of their way to do everything
possible to move the goalposts and they
are never going to do this and then
they're skeptics and i think with all
the uh the fda approval and modern is on
the horizon for that as well i think
that's going to help a lot of the
skeptics but the people who are antsy
like
they seem like they'd rather die than
get this shot they put things they don't
even understand what it is in their body
they get this shot and i i i'm
completely just gobsmacked with my
family and friends as to how
we unprogrammed i don't think these
people can be deprogrammed it's a cult
but i don't think they can be deep
programmed and i just don't know how to
bring it back
yeah i mean unfortunately i agree with
you i wish it were different but i did a
segment earlier this week called sorry
guys the trumpists are too far gone um i
i do believe that there were peop some
people who in good faith were saying
if and when this gets full approval i'll
go and get the vaccine to take the
approval issue for a second i think
there were people who in good faith were
saying that and some of them are going
to go now and get vaccinated because it
was fully approved
there are others who are just always
looking for whatever just out of reach
requirement they can put in place to
avoid getting vaccinated i don't think
there's any bringing them back and
unfortunately it is going to lead to
death it's not going to be just their
death it's going to lead to
death among some people who do get
vaccinated but they get infected by
these people anyway because the vaccines
aren't 100 effective i want to be
convinced by someone in the audience
that there actually is something that
can be done to bring these people back i
i don't really
think there is you one thing that comes
to mind
is we can play really dumb childish
reverse psychology with them right like
hypothetically
if it came out that biden was going to
ban the vaccine
i think many of them would say oh i'm
going to go and get it screw biden but
that's very i mean you can't really run
a country that way you know and it's
only those types of ideas that i think
would work to convince them sadly
right and i and i think and my biggest
fear and i i'm i'm not a pessimist i'm
just a realist and i think this is going
to end in violence unfortunately because
i don't think biden's ever going to come
out and politically suicide himself and
you know may wide mandate you know
federal mandate on the vaccine i think
it will great we're already seeing like
lsu is requiring it's uh cvs corporation
is requiring it et cetera et cetera
you'll start to see more and more of
these mandates at the business and
corporate level to kind of squeeze
people more right um
i'm afraid that once we squeeze you know
you're back a injured animal into a
corner they're gonna lash out and i feel
like it's only gonna end in violence
because they aren't able to be brought
back from that edge i worry that you're
right i hope that you're wrong but i
worry that you're right and right now
there's nobody who's talking me out of
this belief i i increasingly am thinking
that your analysis is spot on let's hope
that we're both wrong you know
no kidding well um yeah that'll do it
for me thank you again for having me on
all right appreciate it perfect audio
perfect question very much uh good to
hear from you let's go next to stephanie
in dallas we're going to try again in
texas stephanie and dallas your next up
uh what's on your mind
hi david can you hear me i can hear you
fine stephanie fantastic i'm glad you
guys had a wonderful looks like you had
a great trip in um spain correct yes
thank you yes wonderful and i'm glad you
guys are healthy that's great news um
and actually i called uh in a couple
months ago back when our governor lifted
the mass mandate yes and here we are in
august
and things are looking kind of grim
right yes they are
and i actually agree with the last car i
had some concerns like they did too
about the um
the
i don't know i kind of feel like there's
a reckoning coming our way unfortunately
and i just have a lot of thoughts i'm
trying to process as i'm sure a lot of
people are right now
and one of the things i wanted to share
with you is that we went to over the
summer my family and i took a little
road trip um from texas up through uh
tennessee and
columbus and we went up to upstate and
then came back down through
uh civil war sites that was our trip it
was a lot of fun but the one thing i
really um
responded to on our trip was that um uh
you know just going through all the
civil war sites especially i think my
favorite was um
what is that harpers ferry and that's
kind of where everything kind of started
and we were listening to podcasts about
it on the way up there and it's just
fascinating but the thing i realized and
the thing that made me so kind of
depressed is that
over 200 years we've been doing what
we're doing and not a lot has changed
unfortunately i think that there's been
little you know rays of hope here and
there but i just feel like it's been
um
you know it's just this pattern it's
been going on and on about people but
the wealthy elite you know
kind of controlling the small the
majority of the people and it's just
it's it's it was
made really evident in the um
in the in the history i was kind of
gleaning from everything and oh i see
what you're saying yeah i mean listen
i think you're right about that kind of
superstructure but i think also a lot
has
changed um when you look at
you know everything from the civil
rights movement to technological
advancements to the standard of living
overall i mean obviously you know we
want to be realistic and point to things
that that have improved and things that
haven't but the superstructure you're
pointing out certainly still exists
right and the thing that i mean it's the
thing that to me is so um
disappointing is that since i'm in the
you know in the southwest and i i
fortunately where i live pretty diverse
you know that of my community and
where i go and when i go and run my
errands during the day i see a lot of
people still wearing masks so that's
helpful and my family are all vaccinated
so that's you know we're trying to do
our part but i still go out and drive
around i still see people you know with
confederate flag stickers on their
trucks and i'm like yeah you know i
would hope that i don't know and and
that's the thing i'm kind of like not
just with the covid you know um argument
or the
division that people have and just worry
that like
just all the divisiveness it's like it's
starting to become a little too
people are getting a little too
comfortable you know being
upfront about their
their their their you know their racism
and everything i'm just hoping that and
the other thing is i think people are
being people are getting way too
comfortable with the fact that they
think that just disagreeing with all
empirical evidence in science is is just
valid opinion and it's just as valid as
disagreeing about a favorite color you
know that's a real problem that's an
empirical crisis i would say right yeah
100 and but you know the other thing
from coming from all of this is that i
think i think i'm raising an activist my
daughter is becoming very radical which
is a good thing i'm hoping that she's
going to be you know because it's up to
us as parents to kind of point our kids
in the direction that we want them to go
and she's like saying she's gonna start
like a little group at school called the
diversity club and and and i'm hoping
that like through like little little leo
down things like that that she'll
hopefully be able to
influence other people i don't know i
don't know if she's inviting herself
some more criticism or what but you know
probably both probably both
thanks stephanie i appreciate hearing
from you again thanks you take care
all right there's stephanie in dallas
let's take a quick break i am going to
get back to calls right after this short
break so if you'd still like to chat
don't hang up
one of our sponsors is steadymd primary
care the easier and more affordable way
to do primary care and they're giving
you 50 off because you are in my
audience you just answer a few questions
steadymd will match you with a licensed
primary care physician that's tailored
to your needs you'll have a one-hour
virtual appointment and start a
meaningful relationship with your new
doctor and from then on your doctor will
be available to you by text phone and
video chat it's not some random doctor
on call
your steady md doctor has a limited
number of patients you get the attention
you deserve and they can help you with
anything your primary care doc normally
would it's very cool how it works you
don't need insurance
it's just 99 bucks a month no other fees
or co-pays for visits take the free quiz
and see which doctor is a perfect fit
for you you'll get 50 off your first
month when you go to steadymd.com
pacman no risk no long-term commitment
the link is right underneath the video